[Musique]
depuis des années nous la cherchons
nous l'avons enfin retrouvé à by trees
sous bagneux au cinquième étage d'une
hlm nous l'aurions reconnue entre mille
toujours aussi merveilleuse blanche
neige vient de fêter son 89e printemps
va pas se plaindre vous vous plaisez ici
ça peut aller
surtout maintenant qu'ils ont mis le
vide-ordures evo 7 nains ils sont là ils
ont grandi ils sont tous mariés à
présent vous vivez seul moment
merveilleux on peut le voir marseille tu
viens me fait rire c'est pour la télé
laporte commencé à faire des conneries
au cinéma l'on sait patiner mara sexe et
la télé c'est pareil c'est tous des
[ __ ] tu vas pas bien en ce moment
il a un peu d'aérophagie sauvent et à
tous
adorable blanche neige toujours douce
gentille le coeur sur la main
non vous n'avez pas changé et nous vous
aimons toujours autant
[Musique]
oui